[Musique]
bonjour à tous alors je suis avignonnais
depuis une vingtaine d'années certains
d'entre vous avignon me connaissent pour
la direction la manufacture un vieux
théâtre me connaissent aussi peut-être
pour mon implication dans la french tech
culture aujourd'hui on m'a demandé de
vous parler d'une autre partie de mes
activités
la création de lieu innovant dans la
culture à partir d'outils numériques et
de leurs interactions avec les
territoires alors je vais tout d'abord
vous parlez d'un ami qui s'appelle
frédéric nicolas et frédéric nicolas il
est une star à bruxelles c'est une
personne qui a créer des atmosphères
dans différents quartiers de la ville
des quartiers qui étaient souvent des
quartiers mal famés des quartiers où il
y avait parfois beaucoup de criminalité
il a développé dans chacun de ces
quartiers des cafés en intégrant toute
une série d'éléments dans ces cafés créé
le lieu
il choisit un nom il crée aussi tous les
éléments de mobilier intérieur
il va jusqu'à créer les accessoires les
verts mais tu as les chaises les tables
sur le petit plan que vous voyez
derrière moi vous voyez les différents
quartiers de bruxelles sur lesquels il a
créé une dynamique une dynamique que
souvent les pouvoirs publics n'avaient
pas réussi à créer dans un seul de ces
cafés que certains d'entre vous
connaissent peut-être si vous connaissez
bruxelles le belga qui est place flagey
il y a trois millions de clients de
visiteurs par an ça vous montre comment
on peut re destiné une cartographie
d'une ville par les lieux par des lieux
bien pensée des lieux chauds et qui ont
chacun leur identité chacun des lieux de
créer frédéric sont différents on voit
qu'il y a un lien entre eux mais ils ont
chacun une antique est très très forte
et ils sont surtout très chaleureux
alors dans un de mes jobs
j'ai été jusqu'à il ya deux ans
directeur artistique de mons 2015
capitale européenne de la culture
alors vous savez ce sont des grands
projets certains d'entre vous ont sans
doute connu marseille provence 2013 et
dans le cadre de mons la thématique du
projet étaient les relations entre
culture et numérique et dans ce cadre-là
assumant la direction artistique de ce
programme numérique
on s'est posé beaucoup de questions avec
mon équipe sur le type de lieu à créer
en fonction de notre ambition qui était
de toucher tous les publics et d'avoir
un spectre aussi large que possible de
personnes qui auraient fréquenté ce lieu
numérique
une autre réflexion elle a été un peu
précipitée par le fait que pour des
raisons que je ne vais pas expliquer ici
on a eu une baisse drastique de notre
budget sur notre budget numérique et ça
nous a amenés à faire vraiment table
rase et à essayer de trouver des projets
qui finalement n'était pas axé sur la
construction d'un grand bâtiment
vous savez par exemple marseille
provence 2013 le mucem et les grands
capitales européennes de la culture ont
chaque fois des projets à plusieurs
millions voire dizaines de millions
d'euros mais d'aller à l'essentiel et
d'essayer de réfléchir comment créer des
lieux qui peuvent attirer un public
maximum et qui finalement nécessite des
investissements relativement faible et
pour ce faire j'ai beaucoup travaillé
mon équipe avec frédéric ni collègues
on a passé plusieurs semaines à imaginer
en faisant table rase de nos perceptions
des lieux habituels des lieux
relativement ostentatoire de culture
comme un théâtre à l'opéra ou un musée
ou un musée numérique de voir comment
repenser un concept différent et nous en
sommes arrivés à créer un café et à
choisir comme lieu culturel pour le lieu
numérique 2015 un café
un café où il n'y a pas de barrière
psychologique autant certains publics
peuvent avoir une barrière pour aller
dans un opéra pousser la porte d'un
opéra pousser la porte d'un théâtre
pousser la porte d'un musée un café
surtout dans l'europe du nord en
belgique pendant de la france c'est un
lieu extrêmement convivial c'est un lieu
où il ya de la mixité sociale
c'est un lieu où on se rencontre c'est
un lieu on parle à l'autre c'est un lieu
où il ya du vivre ensemble et donc on
s'est dit finalement vu notre objectif
de toucher un maximum de public
nous allons faire un café est ce qu'à
fait on l'a appelé café europa puisque
on était dans le cadre d'une capitale
européenne de la culture et qu'on
souhaitait s'élargir un public européen
sur l'image que vous voyez derrière vous
voyez les éléments de base de
construction de ce projet qu'on a
développée avec frédéric mais aussi avec
des compagnons du devoir basé dans le
nord de la france à jeumont et vous
voyez on a utilisé des containers de
récupération des containers en fin de
vie qui ont une vingtaine d'années
d'expérience qui coûte un milliard
d'euros chacun et on a conçu une
ambiance extrêmement chaude en utilisant
des maths d'autres matériaux de
récupération comme des palettes en bois
et donc on a développé un lieu une
architecture qui a pratiquement aucune
empreinte au niveau écologique puisqu'on
utilise uniquement des matériaux de
récupération et on a créé un peu dans
l'esprit du travail de frédéric dans ces
cafés à bruxelles une ambiance
extrêmement chaude une ambiance de
bien-être dans laquelle on a pu
développer toute une série d'activités
avec des tas de publics différents
des ateliers pour les jeunes des
ateliers pour les familles des
résidences d'artistes et ça extrêmement
bien fonctionné on est allé jusqu'au
bout de notre raisonnement dans une
version postérieure du projet en
réduisant la surface à 70 mètres carrés
et en prenant comme slogan concentrer la
créativité d'un continent dans 70 m² et
pourquoi minimiser l'espace parce que de
par l'exploitation des premiers mois on
a remarqué peu plus l'espace était petit
était compacte plus il y avait eu
d'interaction entre les genres entre le
public qui visitait ce lieu
deux projets spécifiques qu'on a
développé le premier un projet de mur
écran vous avez sans doute en voyage en
vue dans les aéroports c'est système de
mur écran se développe depuis plusieurs
années et où il ya essentiellement des
publicités on a détourné ce type de
dispositif pour créer dans le café une
connexion à travers l'europe à travers
le territoire européen
un des grands enjeux des capitales
européennes de la culture c'est de
relier les citoyens européens entre on
sait que l'intégration européenne n'est
pas facile que les nouveaux arrivants
notamment d'europe centrale et d'europe
de l'est ont énormément de difficultés à
s'intégrer dans la construction
européenne est donc un des objectifs des
capitales européennes de la culture
c'est d'essayer de pallier à cela en
créant des liens en criant tu es un
sentiment commun d'identité et par ce
système de mur écran à l'échelle 1 sur 1
puisque vous voyez sur cet écran les
personnes à qui vous parlez à l'échelle
humaine à la taille humaine dont vous
avez vraiment une impression de
continuité de l'espace
on a créé des activités partagées entre
différentes villes européennes y compris
des villes frontières européennes où il
ya des enjeux à ses fondamentaux comme
sarajevo comme kaliningrad qui est une
enclave russe dans le territoire
européen entre la pologne et la lituanie
un autre projet qu'on a fait c'est de
travailler sur des montée en compétence
par des formations des citoyens et des
habitants qui venait donc à feurs opa
sur la création de mobilier qui l'ont
design et eux mêmes et qu'on leur a
appris à fabriquer sur place avec toute
une approche open source comme anne est
une approche d'un lieu qui se construit
par les personnes qui fréquentent ce
lieu et qui montent eux mêmes en
compétences dans un esprit logiciel
livres et commons
je vais vous parler maintenant d'un
deuxième projet qui est un peu la
continuité de ce projet j'ai un autre
ami qui s'appelle didier fusiller avec
qui j'ai beaucoup travaillé quand
j'étais à mons puisqu'il dirigeait la
scène nationale de maubeuge et nous
étions dans une scène transfrontalière
nous avons fait pendant une quinzaine
d'années beaucoup de projets ensemble
didier est devenu le président du parc
de la villette en 2016 et n'a contacté
ayant vu ce que nous avions fait à café
europa pour un projet très singulier un
projet qui était une première à
l'échelle mondiale il a obtenu des
directeurs et des présidents de huit
musées nationaux le louvre le centre
pompidou le château de versailles le
musée national picasso
universcience la cité des sciences la
villette et la philharmonie la
possibilité d'accéder à des parties de
leurs collections numérisées et son
objectif en arrivant à la présidence de
la villette était de ne plus essayer
d'attirer les jeunes des cités nord de
paris à la villette sur le parc de la
villette
mais de créer des centres culturels de
nouvelle génération qui répondent à un
souci d'intégration de ces jeunes dans
la communauté culturelle et artistique
nationale et européenne
le premier projet de ce musée numérique
qui est intégrée dans un dispositif un
peu plus large qui s'appelle micro folie
a été implanté à sevran sevran c'est une
ville au nord de paris pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas qui est une zone de
sécurité prioritaire c'est une des zones
où il ya les plus hauts taux de
criminalité en france où il ya
énormément de radicalisation comme on en
parle depuis quelques années et
l'objectif était d'installer ce premier
musée numérique à sevran vous voyez une
vue de la cité de sevran et le type de
territoire sur lequel on travaille à ce
franc il n'y avait pas
espace pour installer amusé numérique
même si on n'avait pas besoin de grandes
surfaces
on est donc parti avec les équipes de la
villa du bureau d'études de la ville est
sur un dispositif très léger en fait
c'est une tante que vous voyez figurer
derrière moi qui est installée au milieu
des tours que vous avez vues sur l'a10
positives que celles de la précédente où
le principe du musée en fait c'est une
évolution de ce que je vous ai présenté
tout à l'heure et du café europa on
avait comme objectif de présenter 65
chef-d'oeuvre de la nation parmi
lesquels des oeuvres numérisées comme la
joconde guernica mais aussi des
statuaire grecque du louvre des vues en
trois dimensions du château de
versailles et avec toute une équipe
multidisciplinaire
nous avons travaillé pendant quatre mois
avec les équipes de la villette pour
définir une scénographie qui permettent
de rendre ces oeuvres
ces chefs-d'oeuvre du patrimoine
national et mondial
accessible la solution que nous avons
trouvée s'est inspiré de l'expérience du
café europa nous avons travaillé avec un
écran monumentale que vous voyez
derrière moi avec cette vue de la
joconde est un système de tablettes les
tablettes permettant d'avoir des
contenus enrichis sur l'écran défile un
film avec 60 chef-d'oeuvre dewi musées
nationaux
vous avez une autre vue du dispositif
d'écran sur les tablettes
vous avez accès à plus de 300
chef-d'oeuvre des musées nationaux
ce type de dispositif
répond à toute une série d'enjeux à
sevran vous donner une idée le coût
d'investissement est extrêmement faible
par rapport à des structures habituelles
construite en dur avec énormément de
coûts d'investissement et de
fonctionnement sur la première année
d'exploitation puisque le premier projet
a été installé à sevran en janvier 2017
on a eu plus de 20000 visiteurs ce qui
est énorme sur un territoire extrêmement
complexe le terrain sur lequel a été
construit ce musée était un terrain de
dealers de drogue pour vous montrer un
peu types d'écosystèmes dans lequel on a
pu
on a travaillé ce qui est également
fondamental dans ce type de projet c'est
le rapport qu'on peut développer avec
les publics en général on a des
approches qui sont assez classique en
terme de médiation avec des équipes de
médiation qui doivent intervenir pour
présenter des contenus essayer d'avoir
des démarches de médiation
ici on est sur un dispositif qui est
relativement autonome le dispositif
d'écran tablette permet à des personnes
pas nécessairement initiés de voyager
dans les trésors de la nation dans les
collections des musées nationaux
j'ai vu par exemple à sevran des femmes
avec foulards qui vivent dans
l'écosystème 2e rang dans des cités de
sevran montrer avec beaucoup de fierté à
leurs enfants les trésors des statuaires
du lot des trésors de statuaire grecque
par exemple
j'ai vu ici à avignon puisque le
festival d'avignon accueilli pendant
trois semaines le dispositif de musées
numérique de manière limitée dans le
temps
j'ai vu un enfant de 9 ans de rognonas
me dire avec beaucoup d'émotion qu'il
avait touché pour la première fois dans
sa vie une tablette numérique
j'ai vu des classes entières arrivé à la
fabrica et à l'ouverture des portes à la
vision du dispositif qui est un
dispositif qui leur parlent avec des
outils numériques avec des tablettes on
rire pour découvrir les trésors de la
nation et et les parcourir avec leurs
professeurs la conception de ces
dispositifs demande énormément de
travail énormément d'équipés
pluridisciplinaires
le message que je voulais vous faire
passer aujourd'hui autour de tous ces
projets c'est un message autour de
l'imaginaire en fait ce musée numérique
est un outil qui nous permet de
travailler l'imaginaire collectif
notre imaginaire collectif aujourd'hui
dans notre société
beaucoup de jeunes de milieux sociaux
défavorisés des cités sont soumis à
énormément de tentatives souvent des
tentatives réussies de radicalisation
ces tentatives de radicalisation elles
se construisent sur un imaginaire un
imaginaire de guerre un imaginaire dont
on parle ces dernières années le projet
de musée numériques proposent leur
proposent leur ouvre les portes d'un
autre imaginaire un imaginaire axée sur
la beauté un imaginaire axé sur un choc
esthétique un imaginaire basée sur des
valeurs qui sont les valeurs de
l'humanisme européen
les valeurs de la république
le l'outil numérique
s'il est bien utilisé de manière non
marchande avec la puissance publique
nous permet aujourd'hui vraiment de
reconsidérer la diffusion de la culture
sur des enjeux comme celui dont je viens
de parler sont vraiment les enjeux de
notre société d'aujourd'hui qui traite
de notre vivre ensemble ensemble d'une
autre sinon j'étais très heureux de vous
parler de ce projet dans une ville
avignon qui est ma ville qui est une vie
qui a une reconnaissance mondiale dans
la drogue décentralisation de la culture
qui est emblématique du vivre ensemble
du partage de la culture qui est la
ville de jean vila la ville de rené char
je vous remercie de votre attention
[Applaudissements]